[Music]  Kim Kardashian shares a sweet snap of  daughter Chicago West I'm really excited  a 37 year old reality star took to  Instagram to share the first filterless  photo of her newborn along with these  adorable videos and since her birth  Kim has shared several pics of her third  child but always accompanied with a  filter over her face it was really tough  for me Kim and hubby Kanye West welcomed  their baby girl in January via surrogate  eats he spoke with shai's glamoc Kris  Jenner  earlier this month where she gushed over  her grand baby she's doing great yeah  she's doing really good she's happy and  everybody's healthy so thrilled  [Music]  [Applause]